con fuertes vientos estás de silenciosas
hélices podrían alcanzar una velocidad
de rotación de 290 kilómetros por hora
el oeste de texas conocido por su
petróleo es también una de las regiones
más ventosas de eeuu rosemary es un
granjero texano de la tercera generación
así es nuestra familia ha estado aquí
desde 1932 desde 2006 se han instalado
43 turbinas eólicas en su granja de 2
mil 800 hectáreas
cohabitan con el algodón y las vacas las
turbinas eólicas no molestan para nada
las vacas al contrario durante el verano
ellas se refugian bajo la sombra de las
apa para evitar el calor de hecho es
bastante gracioso darle a seguir la
sombra durante el día estos gigantes de
110 metros de alto les pertenecen a
empresas de producción de electricidad
que alquilan las tierras de ross cada
turbina genera 5 mil dólares por año lo
cual representa el 20 por ciento del
volumen de negocios del granjero cuando
uno es agricultor uno siempre busca
medios para aumentar sus ingresos
[Música]
las turbinas eólicas tenían sentido
monopolista en toda la tierra y ayudan a
pagar algunas facturas el oeste de texas
es una región árida sujeta a grandes
periodos de sequía pero gracias a los
ingresos ofrecidos por la industria
eólica muchos agricultores al borde de
la quiebra han podido conservar sus
tierras en este estado republicano el
argumento económico es el que favorece
la ecología el mercado de lógico es
bastante nuevo en esta región real
invertir en esto ayudamos a diversificar
el mercado de la energía no sólo para
nuestros propios intereses sino también
para los de eeuu y el resto del mundo
texas en se convirtió en el primer
productor de energía eólica en eeuu por
sí solo el estado cuenta con una
capacidad de producción de 29 mil
megavatios dicho de otro modo si texas
fuera un país esto lo situaría en el
sexto lugar mundial de productores de
este tipo de energía rodrigo what's él
es el abogado de referencia en derecho
de energía eólica
explica la expansión de los renovables
gracias al estatus tan independiente de
texas porque aquí no existen las
regulaciones federales del mercado es
como en la época del lejano oeste se
puede hacer cualquier cosa con un
terreno obtener contratos de
arrendamiento no hay necesidad de
obtener un permiso y después vender su
producción a la población local además
se tiene derecho a beneficios fiscales
aquí no existe todo el papeleo y las
dificultades administrativas como en
otros estados
por eso en texas esta industria no ha
dejado de crecer desde sus inicios
la llegada de lo renovable mejoró de
manera considerable la economía de la
región y reactivó la demografía las
empresas eólicas fueron grabadas con
impuestos lo cual mejoró la base fiscal
de la región en 20 años pasamos de 435
millones a 3000 millones de dólares y
esto produjo la creación de empleos la
apertura de hoteles y de restaurantes
los miles de empleos generados por la
industria eólica crean vocaciones en
sweetwater autoproclamada la capital
mundial del viento la universidad
técnica ofrece un programa especializado
para formar a los futuros técnicos de la
industria acuerdate primero lo mantienes
en bajo hasta que llegue luego los
sueltas y verificas de nuevo al final lo
apagas para hacer los arreglos le enseño
a los alumnos cómo trabajar con máquinas
que tengan un alto torque de rotación es
una habilidad que se utiliza en el
momento de ponerla en funcionamiento y
del mantenimiento según las estadísticas
nacionales el empleo de los técnicos de
la industria eólica debería aumentar un
61 por ciento para 2029 para este
aprendiz de 20
y esa es la garantía de un futuro
profesional estable es un sector que no
deja de crecer y eso es lo que yo quiero
trabajar en un ámbito donde siempre haya
trabajo
además me parece que los comportamientos
actuales no son muy buenos para nuestra
atmósfera
entonces pasar por completo a la energía
renovable por supuesto que ayudar a la
industria del futuro es también la
apuesta que hizo en el gigante francés
de la energía salió a la conquista del
oeste estadounidense
el rotor tiene un diámetro de 140 metros
entre más grande sea el rotor más
podemos atrapar el viento en 2020 a
pesar de la pandemia la empresa
desarrolló seis nuevos parques eólicos
en el país entre ellos este al sur de
dallas que hoy recibe la visita de su
director general
el generador está entonces situado
arriba y luego baja la electricidad sí
así es
pasa por estos cables hasta aquí gracias
a sus turbinas eólicas angy les
suministra energía a las municipalidades
pero también a grandes empresas como wal
mart amazon y microsoft
la energía eólica representa un cuarto
de la producción de electricidad de
texas y debería alcanzar el 40% en 2022
para que las empresas sigan su avance
hacia la transición energética y la
energía renovable es necesario que el
precio del mega wats por ahora también
sea igual de competitivo como lo es para
las demás fuentes de energía de las
mentawi maker
basta con mirar alrededor para entender
que estamos invirtiendo de manera
considerable en estas granjas eólicas y
para que este movimiento continúe es
esencial que el gobierno ponga a
disposición créditos fiscales para la
inversión
la administración bailén fijó objetivos
ambiciosos y hay una voluntad de
descarbonizar que no existía hace 10
años
en su plan masivo de renovación de las
infraestructuras
joe biden tiene previsto otorgar varios
miles de millones de dólares de ventajas
fiscales y de nuevos gastos para las
energías renovables pero el futuro de
este proyecto sigue siendo incierto
antes de ver el día deberá primero ser
aceptado por el congreso